welcome everybody
to blizzcon we know that you all
want to hear more about overwatch 2.
allow us to invite you behind the scenes
to explain more of what we're doing and
why
everybody please hit record fingers
crossed we lost scott
it's off to a good start this is going
great
we've been assembling one of the best
teams that i have ever worked
with i'm nervous and i am so proud
of the progress that we have made
together
we really liked the stylized drop down
imagine that
it's coming forward boom boom this
starts to spin the scale and the scope
of this game
have meant that we've needed to grow
substantially just have we have to
sorry let me start overall i think we've
done
incredibly well as team moving to work
from home
oh shadow play there have definitely
been challenges
but the team is really putting
everything we've got behind this game
to me it's the next big step in the
overwatch universe
new heroes game modes major story beats
with competitive and pve i see overwatch
2 as the overwatch for all of my friends
you know we're always inspired by what
historian franchise development does
with their animated shorts
we really wanted to bring that cinematic
experience into the game
you can invest in your heroes and grow
them over time
i'm super geeked out about overwatch too
i can't wait for people to play this
game
it just gets better and better there are
some things that we just can't do
without a sequel
so thank you so much for your patience
so far
and i hope you enjoyed this behind the
scenes look at overwatch 2.
all of our players at home they want to
see one of the new maps
that we've never talked about before
really i can just like
i can just talk about anything that i
want to
yeah you're you're serving this up to
the guy that is like
unintentionally leaked information in
past
interviews you can do it officially now
okay so one of the maps that i'm
i'm most excited for in overwatch 2
is our rome map
we always want overwatch to feel like
this globetrotting adventure for our
players
so we're having a lot of fun coming up
with the overwatch version of rome
we wanted a very romantic sort of this
powerful feeling of old world
architecture
one of the most exciting things for me
is the early building of these maps
where we get to sit down together with
key people from the environment team
level designers
effects groups we'll spend some time
talking about moments in the game that
we really want to see
like the colosseum or a grand view of
the hills of rome in the backdrop
and then we'll go back and do a paint
over or we'll do a concept painting of
certain things based on that
we try to draw inspiration from as many
different sources as possible
for example one of our environment
artists had just taken a trip
to rome and he returned with thousands
of pictures and was so excited
to work on a map set in italy there's a
lot of ancient architecture in rome that
represents the empire that it used to be
so
we brought some of that back some of the
things that are destroyed in real life
we kind of rebuilt in a kind of
overwatch style
it's one of the most beautiful pieces of
environment art that i think we've made
for the entire game and it just
absolutely took my breath away
[Music]
can we reveal more maps yes scott
scott why don't you have the honor why
don't you reveal
like is there an artifact like let's
pick an artified one
i know what map i want to talk about
it's the one that i just get super
excited about
new york city new york city is
just an amazing overwatch location
we're really striving to make it as
authentic as possible while still
putting this overwatch spin on it
there's a lot of amazing buildings and
architecture pieces that just especially
for artists stands out a lot
and they usually use this kind of art
deco style from the 1920s 1950s
we started in an area that's a little
bit like the village
there's some smaller shops there there's
a fire station
little pizza places and things that
people that are familiar
with new york city will either recognize
or maybe
see the reference that we're trying to
make with some of our different
locations
it feels like something you haven't seen
in other games before because it's
uniquely
overwatch
well we should move on otherwise we just
have to reveal
more maps so we were talking about pvp
and you know one thing that i think is
really interesting about
pvp and overwatch too is some of the
philosophical changes
we're making to the approach pvp feels
different new we're upgrading our combat
feel
the roles are playing differently when
it comes to all new maps
it's a pretty big departure uh from
where we are
on live right now so i i can't wait to
see where we end up with it by the time
we launch this thing
we're also experimenting with the idea
we call role passives which are passive
abilities that a hero can have based on
what role they are
for example currently in our internal
builds uh the tank heroes
all have knockback reduction against
them and they also generate less
ultimate charge for enemies they're
shooting at them
damage dealing heroes have a movement
speed bonus which is great for
flanking around the map and healing
heroes support heroes have
uh automatic healing that kicks in after
they haven't taken damage for a while
very similar to mercy's passive but a
little bit of a lower rate
one of the more shocking changes that
we've been exploring
in overwatch 2 pvp is it changed the
tank roll
entirely that's applied to all of the
tanks
we want to try to make them more
toe-to-toe
brawlers and less characters that just
stand back and protect
other people so for example for
reinhardt we've given him two charges of
fire strikes so we can throw
fire strikes a lot more aggressively and
more often also his charge
he's able to cancel it now and you can
steer it more aggressively so you can
you know not quite turn a corner but you
can definitely more accurately pin
targets and
because you can cancel it allows you to
use it much more aggressively and
you know really go after those key
targets without feeling like you're
gonna sacrifice
you know all of your positioning
everything to get there he's almost more
terrifying now with us to be able to
unleash his full arsenal more often than
kind of just being the guy with a shield
the changes to reinhardt that we're
trying and
they might not shift that's just the
reality but the changes
that we're trying right now are to try
to embrace
more of that instinct that players have
when they want to play
a big burly character that looks
aggressive
and feels like it should be aggressive
shortly after blizzcon we we spun up
this group our combat feel group
um to really just work on what happens
when a player holds the trigger we're
putting a ton of effort into
looking at all of our characters um and
trying to
give them even a more visceral weapon
feel
from sound to vfx to animation
to the design of these units all new
sounds for
for a lot of our weapons in the game and
a whole new sound system
that's driving it and we didn't just
level up a unit
we leveled up the rest of the game
when we first started working on
overwatch you know we spent quite a bit
of time working on
gunfire sounds and just just general
combat feel to make it feel really
awesome
we're revisiting pretty much everything
nothing's off the table so we're looking
at
even kind of small things such as quick
melee attacks that every hero has so
they have kind of new audio paths and a
new kind of
feel and visual effect when you hit
things one of the bigger efforts we're
undertaking for overwatch 2
is what we're calling our weapon 2.0
sound pass
what this is a big overhaul to the
weapon systems in the game
that means the way the gun feels in your
hands you could feel the ammo running
out as you're getting lower on the clip
we've really tried to
amplify those sounds to better
encapsulate the gameplay
and the play that comes with overwatch
too
another key for the weapons was getting
them to feel like they're in the
environment this meant working with
convolution reverb it's a new system
that we've implemented into overwatch
it's a way that we can capture the
acoustics of an environment
and transport it onto the sounds that
we're using so we went and captured
tales
of guns in different environments
through our weapon shoots
and then we've cut them and applied it
so that we can support a lot more
environments
now we're sporting outdoor urban
outdoor warehouse tales
tight tunnels small rooms and it gives a
lot more presence to the weapons in the
way that they react
in the world the shooter genre has
evolved a lot since overwatch one came
out
on top of that i think we really want to
push the visceral nature of how we do
combat
so we focused a lot not just on the
wonderful sound effects but also with
how the the gun moves as you shoot you
know so you can really feel
every single shot leaving the chamber
and there's a lot of subtle little
tweaks we have to do
on the gameplay engineering side to make
that feel really visceral
everything from making sure that the
camera shakes are crisp
making sure that if you get shot you
know exactly these tight indicators show
up on the outside of your reticle
all these things play into making the
game feel not just
tight and responsive but also modern and
up to date
take 76 for example what we wanted to do
in overwatch 2 with his weapon was to
make it really
feel incredibly powerful and that
happens with a bunch of different
elements that mix together
but it really feels like the gun is
almost just outside of your control
a lot of that comes down to this camera
shake technology where every set every
time you fire the weapon
you want to feel like it's running
through your entire body and the camera
shake gives that extra bite to every
single shot out of the chamber
it makes him feel really great you guys
got a sneak peek of
sojourn from last blizzcon she's been
under development for quite a while and
she's actually quickly at this point
become
a lot of people's favorites in-house
when we look back at
overwatch when it was originally created
um there was a lot of heroes that were
made
from a gameplay standpoint kind of
surrounding a weapon type for example
pharah was based on a rocket launcher
hero
widowmaker is clearly like kind of the
sniper we thought there was a weapon
that was kind of
missing that would be a lot of fun to
play with and that's a railgun it's so
much fun in the play test to have this
really powerful shot that can
you know rip through enemies if you
really are accurate with it and she's
she's all about that aim skill so if you
got that aim skill you'll love her
we're still exploring new game modes and
we're
also reevaluating older game modes
that people are more critical of you
know we're of the mindset
maybe maybe 2cp doesn't exist in
overwatch too
and maybe there's a new cool game mode
that replaces it
we really want overwatch 2 to feel like
the next evolution a true
sequel to the first game
not an add-on it's not a small part it's
not an
extension of the original game this is
an evolution and a replacement to the
original game
and i think it's exciting
hero missions are probably one of the
things that's the hardest to wrap your
head around if you've never
played one of them
[Music]
the goal around hero missions is for
these to be
this co-op pve experience
i personally only play competitive mode
like i'm all about that competition
and i have friends that they don't want
to do that at all so i'm really looking
forward to a game that i can play
hours and hours with with my friends who
aren't in competitive and it's also
something that i'm interested in
hero missions are the content that
people are playing
as they are leveling up their heroes and
so for
a system like this to really sing you
need
a lot of mission we don't want players
who feel like they're just in this grind
to get to the top
and there's a lot of really really good
back end technology that we're exploring
so the heroes are constantly bringing
their personality
and some light story to these hero
missions as well
the goal is to make as many as possible
hundreds
of hero missions we've explored a lot of
different ways of getting
to that much content so have like
different sets of enemy units that
people will be fighting against
and there's different hero mission types
at the same time
hero missions can take place in all of
the multiplayer maps that we've done
and we're also adding new spaces onto
some of these maps
it's a huge challenge for the art team
we take maps that
a lot of people love and recognize and
we have to add a lot more
art and level design to it in this one
hero mission play test
we came up to an area in king's row that
usually has a gate on it
suddenly that gate opened and i saw a
new area of king's row that i had never
seen before
you may be playing a payload game type
and the payload may decide to take this
new route instead of
going the usual route that was really
really cool it was like this
eye-opening special moment
lan are lead tech artists on the
environment side
very early on our own free time made a
prototype of a sandstorm
on the temple of anubis map and at the
time we didn't know what we wanted to do
with that but it looked
awesome we looked at and went oh my god
we absolutely have to do this
so we put some new technology in place
that allows us to do this dynamically
you'd start the mission off
clear day midway through the mission
suddenly this
sandstorm or heavy weather would show up
it made the world just feel so much more
alive
there's a sunset daytime nighttime but
depending on where you are in the world
these look different
california or hollywood would have what
we call a california sun
new bonnie there's a great african sun
that happens there you start to get a
sense of space
and mood this is what really brings the
levels to life
for me the dynamic world is exciting
just seeing these dramatic
landscapes the wind and the atmosphere
blowing by it's a much more
cinematic experience for the player
before you start a mission you look at a
map
it's nighttime in necropolis or there's
a sandstorm in necropolis
players can make some comp choices based
on knowing this information
characters like hanzo or widowmaker
start to be a little more valuable
because they have
abilities that allow them to see through
the sand more clearly
are we going to talk about any of the
types of objectives
in hero missions yeah let's let's talk
about the objectives
players are being asked to do different
things from one hero mission to the next
so that they all feel really
fresh to the player for example we have
gathering return
where you're trying to go and grab these
different canisters to kind of safeguard
them so they don't go off and affect the
population in the negative way
it creates this really cool tension in
the world where on the one hand you're
trying to split up and go grab all these
canisters to be as efficient as possible
but at the same time now you're having
these sort of special enemy units spawn
that are really difficult and if you
kind of get caught by yourself
it turns into a pretty bad situation
really quickly it feels extremely
cooperative and like a very different
way to interact with the overwatch
universe
we're experimenting with all sorts of
ideas and just internally we have names
like
wall of death scavenger hunt and kill
quests and
all these new mechanics and enemies for
people to experience
players will be able to jump in night
after night play different hero missions
and then work through the progression
system leveling up their heroes
[Music]
at blizzcon in 2019 we started to talk
about
progression and we showed the very early
version of our talent system which i
think was really cool we had that one
talent where like
nate became the rolling snowball which
was a big hit
we've really blown that system out i'm
really excited about talents you can
play the same hero in so many different
ways now with the skill tree
you can have fun every night doing
different things and kind of
experimenting
yeah the talent system is like really
deep
and rich and every single hero has
different trees you might
open up 76's tree and as you're leveling
and picking new talents you're starting
to feel your hero change
we've had some pretty hilarious versions
of the healing one
where his biotic field travels with him
it also repulses enemies we called it
the snow plow build
where 76 is like running through spaces
pushing enemies away from them
designing these is super fun because
it's like we get to break all the rules
that we've sort of established
for ourselves and we get to really take
the gloves off and do crazy things like
junkrat can do with grenade launchers
and we've had mercy be able to
area effect rez their whole team at once
at super long range through walls
it's been a ton of fun kind of like mad
scientists making all this stuff you're
all used to using these kind of kinetic
weapons like soldier 76's rifle
or fire attack like what reinhardt's
flame strike does
as soon as you start to mutate these
things with talents all of a sudden
maybe you're doing
freeze damage or electrical damage but
it gives the animators a bunch of crazy
opportunities you know the animations
are going to change to show them
freezing and shattering
and if you you know shock someone with a
lightning attack they can shake in place
and stun maybe chained to other enemies
all sorts of stuff to make you feel like
you're controlling the battlefield
in novel ways as a huge rpg nerd myself
the first time i opened up the talent
tree systems it was like
oh my gosh this is this is speaking my
love language like
i just want to plan and i want to see
like where do i want to invest and how
am i going to play this character
yes it's so great you like you start at
the bottom of the tree
like oh my gosh exactly like tracer gets
to do what
and then you start working and kind of
planning how you're going to get down
there
it's like oh it's so fun
when we look back at blizzcon 2019
and we talk about some of the criticisms
that we had
one of them as a development team that
we felt was that the combat
was just not engaging enough so the fact
that our combat
wasn't highly engaging to us as players
meant that we had a problem with the
enemy units
and that they just weren't feeling
interesting enough
just because we show something to the
public it doesn't mean that that is what
it's going to be if we make discoveries
where
things aren't working how we want
they're not reading how we want they're
not fun enough
we're totally down to reinvestigate
reiterate and just
really find ways to level kind of all
aspects of things until they feel good
i would say a major focus of all of
2020 was to make the null sector
enemy units more engaging and some of
this was
adding new units and evolving other
units that we had
interesting combat for us is varied
combat for
us so sometimes we're gonna ask you to
protect something
in overwatch too sometimes we're just
gonna ask you
to get someplace sometimes we might ask
you to escort something across a map
while it's being attacked and so it's a
different type of spawning and it's a
different type of units that are that
are in there and it's a simpler
objective
there's a lot of units aaron is talking
about lots of different units lots of
different types they serve different
purposes you do different things to them
it's really going to help a lot of us
find the fun and make sure that
overwatch 2
is a blast one of those sets of of
enemies is what we internally call
objective units
and they're typically units that don't
even attack
players the simplest version would be
something like the breacher it's two
legs with this huge bomb on its back
it was built to do one thing slowly and
methodically
march towards its objective and then it
transforms
and the bomb opens up like a flower
starts spinning and
charging up and you hear this awesome
sound and you know you have a little bit
of time before it's gonna explode and
you have to take it out
we have units like the slicers which you
guys have seen before they they're
little
we call them the chickens like little
chicken snacks they're right there
really fast
you know we have a guy who's friendly
right now who flies and drops these
bombs that create these
kind of ever expanding smoke fields that
you have to escape from because they're
super deadly
so you really get to use your mobility
options to kind of escape that there's
things like
the polar you could be moving through
these
darker alleys and as soon as you hear
that polar spawn
it suddenly becomes like really spooky
and kind of scary
this very tall elegant looking character
that's blindfolded
three orbs that circle around her as her
eyes
and we basically spun those orbs around
her head as a big tell
launch them at the player and then
activate this tractor beam and it's
bringing you in and bringing you in and
then you get this
awesome like anticipation of the hair
opening up so you know what's about to
happen
one thing we've just recently been
experimenting with is this idea of
elite units we didn't want the elite
units to feel like they're just
oh this guy's got double health and
double damage we want to make sure the
units feel like they have different
behaviors and have different attacks
so for example an omnic run normally
he just kind of he fires his gun he dies
pretty simply
if you fight elite crunch his weapon
fires in a burst fire pattern it's very
deadly if you're close
and if you manage to take them out they
don't just die right away they instead
can crawl on the ground
towards you and you you know you try to
back away um because
you know if they get to you they can
explode
artillery at blizzcon we're all just
staring at this
and we're like what is what are we going
to do to level this up one of the things
we really
felt wasn't coming through was the
damage states we intend for players to
shoot these guns off
but currently it's not reading as
something that can happen in the game
easily
we change the design we change the
animation and we go back and forth and
just continually iterate
we decided hey you know what we're gonna
just delete half of these
damage states so now it's super readable
from an animation standpoint
we decided on spinning barrel version
just did this really nice kickback
the tip of the barrel opens up when it's
about the firing
shifts into place and it's
really amazing to be fighting an
artillery unit and you can see the guns
on the side and as you're shooting the
guns they're actually visibly taking
damage and then
you can blow them off and it reacts and
kind of stumbles to the side and really
makes you feel like you're there and
it's super fun
in a lot of the stuff we've showed so
far you're fighting a mill sector these
are evil killing machines
intent on marching you down the way
you're going to stop them is by shooting
them
and we want to make sure that feels
responsive and visceral really making
sure that when they take a hit
it feels like their whole body has been
punched almost like hit by a truck
that's what really sells this fantasy
that you're playing these superheroes
one of the cool pieces of technology
that we created was what we call chain
hit reactions
often times you'll find no sector
bunched up marching
maybe a half a dozen units of rest you
expect if you shoot one
they're going to knock them with their
buddies so we made that happen
turns out it's really fun too
one of the things that we showed last
year at blizzcon was the new looks for
our heroes
the theory kind of going in was like you
want to preserve the essence of your
hero
but also kind of show that the hero's
evolved and kind of change and move
forward
so we have a lot more new looks so i'm
excited to see how
players and fans react to all of the
ones that we've done so far maybe we'll
share some of those
new looks today which would be cool
we're going to reveal mccree's new look
for overwatch 2 as well as farah
and we're really excited to show off
some of our first villains
with reaper and widowmaker but first i
wanted to talk a little bit about
technical wear kind of like technical
clothing what that really is is
using you know very techy fabrics as
well as
you know having very intricate but
functional straps designed in a way that
is very aesthetically pleasing with
mccree we took a couple different
approaches
he's got this classic cowboy look that
it's really hard to mess with because
if you try to make him too sophisticated
or too techy it might not feel right for
the character but
as a concept artist you always want to
change things around and try different
shapes
and silhouettes so we did identify as
red sarape as
the main thing for mccree we also tried
a couple different things with increased
cowboy hat
we didn't really want to mess with that
too much because that's a very iconic
part of him
so that's another piece that we that we
kept we tried some
retro cowboy looks that mixed in some
tech here and there
some that were a little bit more techy
than others some that were a little bit
more
classic cowboy we gave him a little bit
of a longer beard
and it really gives them a nice kind of
like a more aging look
what's different about pharah than some
of our other heroes is
farrah's completely covered in armor we
didn't want to change her silhouette too
much
it was more about experimenting on
different colors so it
felt really appropriate for her to be
the one to hearken back to those
original overwatch colors
of white and blue one of the things that
we wanted to update on farah was her
visor
instead of being completely opaque and
reflective we tried a little bit more of
a transparent approach
and being able to see through it a
little bit now allows us to see some of
her
some more of her emotions reaper was
actually the ones i was very excited to
work on because
i could see a lot of potential in how we
can integrate his cloak
and his cowl and his armor and how we
can make all those shapes really sing
within that classic you know reaper
silhouette
we tried a couple takes with the first
pass like completely silver arms
more layers to his jacket reaper's
basket is obviously
pretty sacred to us but the thing you'll
notice immediately is that it's now
completely silver
instead of the bone white he's got this
like almost like deadly edgy silver
that just gives him that classic reaper
look with widowmaker we started with the
ida stage exploring a breath of ideas
we tried things like a more insectoid
approach treasure hunter
one of them made her feel like a classic
bond villain so we kind of steered it
back towards one of the more cyberpunk
looking ones almost like a futuristic
femme patel which is basically what
widowmaker is but she even feels
more upgraded so i'm super glad that we
went down this route
we played with different hairstyles too
widowmaker has the really long ponytail
that's
really key part of her look and really
liked the hairstyle on
one of the designs that was more of a
braid and it was really interesting
look that also preserves widowmaker's
original silhouette with that long
ponytail
we've been working a lot with our domino
engine and making our cloth look better
now that we have this cloth tech we're
going to be able to
make some really cool unique silhouettes
that will help them stand out from other
heroes
we put a lot of time and effort into our
face rig and what i mean by that is
we'll be able to get really close
to these characters and it's gonna feel
really cool it is absolutely worth
the time and effort to invest in the
technology and that way we can make
these characters
do more things that we haven't really
been able to do before it's been super
exciting working on the new looks for
overwatch 2
and it's just been so inspiring to watch
the team try things that we've never
tried before
and i just can't wait to show off more
in the future
overwatch 2 is probably the
largest opportunity we've had since the
inception of the franchise
to really expand what overwatch even
means
to our players in zero hour we saw that
some of the heroes
got back together but we're also seeing
that there seems to be
a second huge omnic uprising
we're gonna learn who's behind that
uprising
why that's happening how globally spread
is it
the story and franchise development
group they were really the torchbearers
of what
the big story is that we were gonna tell
for this game
we have a lot of interaction with them
they're working on
in-game cinematic intros and outros for
every one of our story missions it's
been really great to see this
collaboration grow and develop
the story is just a little more
integrated into our missions than it
ever really has been before
all the available heroes get dialogue
for a given mission
we have npcs we have multiple hero
choices
we have all sorts of events that are
happening that are driving players
to interact with each other or parts of
the
environment or other characters the
world of overwatch is this bright shiny
future
so how do you take that bright shiny
future and create conflict in it
how dark can the world of overwatch go
the different
challenges that these characters are
going to have to overcome in overwatch 2
are things that they haven't ever dealt
with before or dealt with on this scale
so what we had to do was literally strip
it down to those bare bones
of where are these characters in their
lives overwatch has been disbanded
and now there's a situation where the
world's in trouble again
and the world needs the heroes again but
they're not allowed to be
doing what they were supposed to be
doing
we started to book these off-site
locations
so we could brainstorm over and over
different versions of what the overwatch
2
story campaign could be and we basically
had these white boards that we were
carting around everywhere the room was
filled with whiteboards and we would
just write every day
story beats with the characters and who
was doing what and where and oh my gosh
we forgot this character
we had these giant sticky notes and each
one of them would be a mission with a
bunch of notes on it you know somebody
say
well what if we moved rio to the end and
they'd physically grab it off the wall
and stick it on the end and we did this
for a while you know until we all felt
that it was
pretty close to what we wanted then we
could send that to our writers rooms the
writer's rooms then had a much
clearer direction of where we wanted
this process to go
ultimately we come up with something
that we think is right
for the game and then we pitch it back
to the game team and they point out
everything that
uh we missed and that allows us to
actually back up and go and make it
right and make it better
because the scale of this story is so
huge it takes place over the whole world
basically
it just requires a constant iteration
constant refinement to make the story as
best as we can make it
from writing we go to storyboards the
storyboards get crafted with the edit
from there it'll go to a previz
department where they'll start to
flush it out in 3d once we've kind of
figured out our camera work and our
cinematography that'll then go to the
animation department
and then we end up going right into the
game engine
one of our challenges was to figure out
how to integrate this story and this
narrative
with the gameplay so if the intro
cinematic ends with this huge battle
this huge war
when you get into the game it has to
mesh and feel the exact same way and
blend together
we really are also trying to get the
music to be equally as consistent from
in-game cinematics straight through to
the mission adam burgess our lead
composer has been working with the igc
team with the game team
developing themes for all the heroes
all of the locations as the cinematic
director
whenever we're crafting should never
override the gameplay we want to make
sure that
the player's experience going from the
cinematic to the gameplay is seamless
and it feels like a completely immersive
experience
the engineers we have to find a way to
actually make that come to fruition
the choreo tool is a tool that allows
people to coordinate different events to
happen at the same time
like in rio if you've played our demo
one of the buildings explodes and so
that kind of event needs to happen as
you're running by and you need to have
it timed because if it blows up too
early then you don't see it
it allows story moments in missions that
interact with the environment that
interact with our characters
the new tech the new abilities that we
have now are allowing us to push our
storytelling farther than
we could have previously what's also
really powerful about cory
is that you know if somebody has an idea
they can mock things up really quickly
we got to show the widowmaker making
this awesome introduction
casey was able to quickly put a really
rough prototype in corio
and philip would come in and on the fly
he's making quick changes they play
tested
something that would normally take weeks
it was done in like a matter of days
each story mission has its own custom
map built for it and these maps are
absolutely gigantic
india is one of our biggest maps and
it's a fun map because it has a few
story beats that we've taken from
recent comics and and characters in the
game
we've written a history for each city so
that the cities feel
lived in and i think that informs the
artists so that they know
like what it is that the city has been
through gotham very was our chance to
show
torbjorn's workshop we created a space
that kind of fits his height so there's
you know step ladders and
scalable tables we designed the space as
if we were a tourbillon
molted steel is pouring out of walls
it's pretty
epic when you walk into it
toronto was under siege by null sector
when the players arrive here there's a
dynamic snowstorm
so as you make your way through the
level the snow is slowly building up
suddenly by the end
the characters are caught in this
gigantic snowstorm and they must fight
their way through
in overwatch 2 we want to give you
choice to be able to play this character
or that character
so we're designing a lot of systems
around how their relationships develop
over the course of
the story missions in the campaign
we have a cast of many characters all on
screen all at the same time
and it's fantastic to actually see them
all interacting and working together in
ways that we've never actually seen
we've always thought about it and hoped
for it but now it's actually happening
it actually requires us to have a whole
new branching dialogue system
if you happen to have genji and mercy in
the second mission of the game you might
get different dialogue
that's about their relationship our
voice actors bring the characters to
life in ways that
everybody has fallen in love with from
inside blizzard to the fans
just to hear this collection of actors
all together
all interacting has been a real treat
i wish people could see how many people
are involved when it comes to something
like telling the story of overwatch
it doesn't just come from a singular
person it comes from a group
and it's a really talented fun group
that all works together
we've been developing what we hope is
one of the best stories ever
there's some key story moments that i'm
really excited about
i really can't wait to see how people
react to it
we've been talking about the game about
the this universe
i know you all love it so much
right now we can sit down and have a
night of overwatch too
and have it be a really fun experience
and i think
we need some more time so we can say
it's perfectly
polished in the way that we want it
we've made such
incredible strides since we first
announced this and showed it to the
community at blizzcon in 2019
the thing that i'm most excited about is
that moment
when we hand the game over to the
players
we want to create something that really
moves people really touches people
that's why we do it we create the game
because we want it to become
part of your life and for you to
experience it
[Music]
for overwatch 2 we're upping the bar
it's kind of five games in one it's a
huge undertaking
the new tech and the new aesthetics for
the new looks bring you closer to the
characters that you love
and we're just getting started the
fidelity of the gameplay experience is
much richer
we are making cinematics that push the
boundary of what we can do
to tell stories we want this dynamic
world we want things to feel alive
i'm really looking forward to being able
to expand the world of overwatch
for our players we're really trying to
tell
this epic story
in order to make a game great it takes
time
energy collaboration we have just an
incredibly professional
team of designers and artists and
engineers we just love bringing this
world to you guys
so many cool characters it's just a
blast working on it
our goal is for overwatch 2 to be the
worthy
successor to the first game to be the
next evolution and to be a true sequel
we have big plans so thank you for
sticking with us
we're going to cross the finish line and
i know it's going to be awesome
i hope people just end up loving playing
it over and over that's what we want to
try and capture
i'm jumping in i'm playing let's go be
[Music]
heroes
you